if you had Joffrey right in front of you
what would you say you definitely put
all out
yeah you you would have to people out
cuz Joffrey is a horrible horrible
person he's that the most absolutely
evil person I've ever seen on the screen
the worst character from across the TV
is character I don't think it can you
can get away from when he decides the
swinging of sidon and kiln aired at the
end of the first series no way Jack
perform that as well it was terrifying
you know there's something really
sinister about the beginning of season 3
when he's watching the fight and
yesterday Tony Wei has to drink all that
wine there's something so kind of
underlying and sinister and just you
know something is bubbling he just plays
it so well when he's nearly pushed over
that Battlement and we all went yes and
then the hand came on our shoulder and
she couldn't do it and so here we are
three series later and there he is still
acting you get rid of Joffrey in any way
how would you do it
yeah
talking to father
I feel like you should get a little
different like a half brown half the
unfitting first of all you push by the
window then then you do the horrible
sort of yeah mafia show the hounds they
come out love bonus definitely just
gobbled up in one bar dragon poison
maybe there's a lot of people around him
who could poison him very easily and
that would be a slow lingering death so
I'd like that I think I think we all
want him out of the way but we don't
want him to go because he's such fun to
watch it's very difficult to say your
favourite moments because some of them
are truly disgusting but as an actor I
mean it's a complete joy to play those
kind of characters Jack Reese and it
plays Joffrey it's an absolute
sweetheart in real life that's the you
know I mean it's such a brilliant actor
I think he's a genius it was Jack in
front of me I give him a big hug that
Jack is actually a very very sweet boy
and very bright very intelligent young
man with a lot of natural talent
it must be father was too he was hated
men in the world Jack who plays was a
lovely fella Joffrey is there such an
unacceptable character you know that he
really deserves a comeuppance of some
kind and I'm sure it will happen